Where are your sons? Are they good?
They left to find work.
-So who'll do the design?
-Fio.
Fio? That little girl?
She's young, but she's got
something my sons don't.
I've known you a long time,
but I think I'll try somewhere else.
Wait!
It is because I'm a girl?
Or because I'm young?
Both, actually.
Well, I can understand that.
Tell me, what's the main thing
a good pilot needs?
Experience?
No. Inspiration.
I'm glad you didn't say experience.
Grandpa says you were very young
when you first soloed.
You were good from the start.
That was 1910. I was 17.
I'm 17 too!
I can't help being a girl,
but we've got your old blueprints.
If it's no good, you don't have to pay.
Okay, Grandpa?
She'll do fine.
I was overhauling engines when I was 12.
Sleep on it.
Shower's hot. Towels on the rack.
Breakfast at seven. Good night.
You're short, but we're friends.
I'll loan you the rest.